>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
WE TOLD YOU EARLIER ITHE WEEK
ABOUT HOW E LEFT IS VERY MAD
AND TRYING TO SHUT DOWN A SITE
CALLED @LibsofTikTok?
WHY ARE THEY SO UPSET?
OVER THE PAST HALF YEAR,IDEO
AFTER VIDEO HAS APPEARED ON
SOCIAL MED SHOWING
SCHOOLTEACHERS BRAGGING
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ABOUT HOW THEY
PUSH THEIR PERSONAL POLITICS
OFTEN WRD AND GRUESOME
POLITICS ON THE SMALL CHILDREN
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE TEACHING.
THE STUDENTS IN QUESTION ARE NOT
TEENAGERS, THEIR KINDERGARTNERS,
FIRST-GRADERS,IDS WHO HAVE NO
RSPECTIVE ON LIFE AND NO POWER
TO FIGHT BACK.
SO MANY PARENTS SAW THESE
VIDEOS, IN SOME CASES ON
@LibsofTikTok, AND THEY WERE
SHOCKED.THEY HAD NO IDEANYTHINGE
THIS WAS HAPPENING IN THE
CLASSROOM.
HAVING SOME PURPLE HAIRED LOSER
IN A NOSE RING CONVINCEOUR SIX
EUROS TO GET A SEX CHANGE IS NOT
WHY MOST PEOPLE SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL.
SO THEY COMPLAINED, THE PARENTS
DID COMMIT ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
REPUBLICAN OFFICEHOLDERS
RESPONDED BY PROMING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
THEY MADE OUT RANGED NOISES, BUT
THEN IN VERY SHORT ORDER THEYMOT
UKRAINE, WHICH I WHAT TY
REALLY CARE ABOUT, NOT YOU.
IN THE END, ONLY ONE STATE
ALLY DID ANYTHING ABOUT THIS,
THAT WOULD BE THE STATE OF
FLORIDA WITH
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
SEVERAL WEE AGO, THE FLORIDA
LEGISLATURE PASSED A LAW BANNING
TEACHERS FROM BRAGGING ABOUT
THEIR OWN LES TO SMALL
CHDREN.
NEWS REPTERS WENT CRA, THEY
DESCRIBE THE LEGISLATION ASHE
"DON'T SAY GAY" BL BUT AS
ALWAYS THATAS A LIE, THE BILL
DID NOT MENTION THE WOR GAY,
NOTHING TO DO WITH
"TUCKER RLSON TODAYS."
FLORIDA VOTERS SEEM TO KNOW THAS
IN FRIDA SUPPORTED THIS LAW.
THE POLLING FIRM PUBLIC OPINION
STRATEGIES FOUND OUT WHY THEY
DO, "FULLY TWO-THIRDS OVOTERS
BELIEVE IT IS INAPPROPRIATE FOR
TEACRS OR SCHOOL PERSONNEL TODIH
CHILDREN IN KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
THIRD GRADE."
WELL, OF COURSE IT IS.
EVERYONE THINKS THAT.
IFHERE IS EVER A LAW THAT
ACCURATELY RLECTED PUBLIC
OPINION, WHICH SHOULD MATTER IN
A DEMOCRACY, THIS WAS THE LAW.
BUT ACROSS THE COURY ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BOB IGER
WAS WAHING AT BOB IGER DID NOT
LIKE IT.
BOB IGER IS THE 71-YEAR-OLD
FORMER --
LAW WAS IMMORAL.
IN AN INTVIEW LATER WITH CNN,
CHRIS WALLACE, IGER EXPLAINED
PREVENTING TEENAGE FROM
PROMOTING GENDER REASSIGNMENT
SUERY TO CHILDRE WAS HARMFUL.
COUL NOT HE SPENT HOURS HARMFUL.
A DISNEY HEADQUARTERS COMEIS
REMARK CAUSED HUGE PROBLEM FOR
THE NEW CEO.
BOB JAY FICK ISOT ESPECIALLY
POLITIL, NOT AN ACTIVIST, HE
IS A MARTING GUY.
HIS RST INSTINCT WAS NOT TO
GET INVOLVED NOT TO COMMENT ON
WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN FLORIDA
AND THAT SEEMEDWISE GIVEN HOW
MUCH AT STAKE DISNEY HAS IN
FLORIDA, THE ONLY TME PARK IN
ORLANDO YOU MAY HAVE HEARD, THAT
IS AN ENORMOUS PHYSICAL ASSET
THAT CANNOT BE LOADED O A TRUCK
AND MOVE SO MAYBE DO NOT --HE RH
EXPANDING MY DISNEY PLANS TO
TAKE A PASS ON THIS CONTROVERSY
BECAUSE THEY MAKE MOVIES NOT
WS.
BUT BOB CHAPEK'S EMPLOYEES H
OTHER IDEAS.
WHIPPED INTO A FRENZY BY THE
FORMER BOSS, BOB IGER, DISNEYSTN
IMMEDIELY.
THEN, BECAUSE HE ISEAK AND NOT
ESPECIALLYRIGHT, BOB CHAK
CAVED TO THEIR DEMANDS.
HE AGREED TO HOLD A TOWN HALL
WITH AGGRIEVED DISNEY EMPLOYEES
WHO WANTED HIM SOMEHOW TO TAKE
CONTROL OF THE FLORIDA
LEGISLATURE.
HERE IS HOW THAT WENT.
>> I HOPE YOU'VE ALL READ MY
MOST RECENT NOTE, IN WHICH I
PLEDGED TO BE A BETTER ALLY FOR
THE LGBTQ+ COMMUNITY, APOLOGIZED
FOR NOT BEING THE ALLY THAT YOU
NEEDED ME TO BE, AND COMMITTED
ENSURING THAT OUR COMPANY
VES UP TO ITS VALUES
YOUR WORDS HAVE MADE A REAL
IMPACT ON ME.
I UNDERSTD THAT WE HAVE MADEMISE
MISTAKES HAV CAUSED, AND I KNOW
THAT OURILENCE WASN'T JUST
ABOUT THE BILL IN FLORIDA, BUT
ABOU EVERY TIME AN INDIVIDUAL
OR INSTITUTION THAT SHOULD HAVE
STOOD UP FOR THIS COMMUNITY DID
NOT.
I WANT TO THANK THE LGBTQIA+
ADVISORY COUNCIL.
>> Tucker: HEY, BOB, WHAT DOES
LGBTQIA STAND FOR
YOU HAVE NO FREAKINGLUE.
THAT IS NOT THE INTERESTING
PART.
THE INTERESTING PART OF WHAT YOU
JUST HEARD WAS "YOUR WORDS HAVE
MADE A REA IMPACT ON ME."
OTHER WORDS, YOU NOW HAV
FULL CONTROL OVER MY ENTIRE
CENTRAL NERVOUSYSTEM, YOU OWN
MY BRAIN, DO WITH ME WHAT YO
WILL, AND THEY DID.
BOB CHAPEK REVERSEDIS
POTION, DISNEY'S POSITION
COMPLETELY, GOING FORWARD,OT
ONLY DIDHE
DISNEY CORPORATION FERVENTLY
DISAEE WITH THE LAW THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE HAD PSED,
ACCORDING TO BOB CHAPEK, DISNEY
HADECIDED TO OVERRIDE THE
EXPRESSED WILL OF FLORIDA'S
VOTERS AND OVERTURN THAT W.
"OUR GOAL  A COMPA," SAID
B CHAPEK, "IS FOR THISAW TO
BE REALED BY THE LEGISLATURE
OR STRUCK DOWN IN THE COURTS AND
WE REMAI COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THE NATIONAL AND
STATERGANIZATIONS WKING TO
ACHIEVE THAT."
WHOA!
[LAUGHS]
WHAT?
YOU THOUGHT IT WAS AN
ENTERTNMENT COMPANY, BUT NO.
FROM ITS HEADQRTERS IN
LOS ANGELES, THE DISNEY
CORPORION HAD NOW DECIDED IT
RUNS THE STATEF FLORIDA.
SO FOR PEOPLEHO WANT TO DEFEND
HER DEMOCRACY, WHI IS A SYSTEM
IN WHICH VOTERS GET TO GOVERN
THEMSELVES, TS WAS QUITE A
DEPARTURE, THIS WAS OLIGARCHY,
CORPATE CEOs DECIDING WHAT
THE LAW SHOULD BE, YEAH, THAT IS
THEIR NEWOSITION.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, DISNE
EMPLOYEES SET ABO TRYING TO
UNDEINE THE INTENT OF
FLORIDS LAW.
IF TEACHS COULD NOONGER
PROMOTE TRANSGENDER IS HIM T
KINDERGARTNERS, DISNEY PLANS TO
STEP INTO THE BACH AND DO IT
THEMLVES.
HERE IS INTERNAL FOOTAGE FROM
DISNEY OBTAINED BY JOURNALIST
CHRIS RUFO.
>> LAST SUMMER, WE REMOVED ALL
OF THE GENDERED GREETINGS AND
RELATIONSHIP LIFEKILLS SO WE
NO LONGER SAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, BS AND GIRLS.
WEAVE TRAED, WE HAVEPROVIDED TRR
CAST MBERS AND IN RELATIONSHIP
TO THAT THEY KNOW IT IS HELLO,
EVERYONE, OR HEL, FRIENDS.
>> Tucker: OH, NO MORE BOYS
AND GIRL.
DISNEYORLD IS NOW NONBINARY.
OKAY.
TH'S THE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION, YOU A NOT
SURPRISED.
WHAT IS SURPRISING IS THATHE
HEAD OF PUBLICLY HELD COMPANY
LIKE DISNEY WOULD ANNOUNCE IN
PUBLIC THAT HE'S IN CHARGE OF A
STATE THAT WE THOUGHTAS RUN BY
THE VOTERS OF THAT STATE.
WELL, IN FLORIDA, RON DeSANTI
NOTICED THIS.
IS THE ELECTED GOVERNORND
HE DECIDED TO FIND OUT HOW DOES
THE SYSTEM WORK?
HE DECIDED TO TEST DEMOCRACY.
SO DURING A SPECI SESSION OF
THE PHOTO LEGISLATU THIS WEEK,
DeSANTIS LED AN EFFORTO
STRIP DISNEY OF WHAT TURNED OUTF
SPECIAL PERKS THAT COMPANY HADE.
YOURE NOT TREATED LIKE DISNEY
WAS TREATED IN FLORIDA.
YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN TREATED THAT
WELL.
SO AFTERHE SPECIAL SESSION, NO
MORE.
WILL DISNEY WORLD OPERATE AS ITY
WITHIN THE STATEF FLORIDA.
THAT IS HOW THEY WERE GERNED,
BY TMSELVES.
AND NOW GOING FORWARD, DISNEY IS
GOING TO HAVE TO PAY ITS TAXES
OH,OW, JUST LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE.
NOW IF YOU HAVE LIVED IN THIS
COUNTRY FOR MORE THA SAY FIVE
YEARS, ASK YOURSELF, WHAT IS THE
POLITICAL PARTY THAT HAS AAYS
TOLD YOU BIG COMPANIES SHOULD
PAY THEIR TAXES?
CORPORATE TAX BREAKS ARE BAD.
OF COUE, THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SO YOU WOULD IMAGINE THE
DEMOCRATS IN FLORIDA WOULD
APPLAUD A MOVE LIKE THIS ONE.
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME YOU HEARD
LIBERALS COMPLAIN ABOUT
STRIPPING TAX BREAKS FROM BIG
BUSINESS?
NEVER BEFORE IN HISTORY, IT HAS.
AND GET IT JUST DIDT HAPPEN.
THESE ARE DEMOCRATS IN THE
FLORIDA LEGISLATURE, ON THE
VERGE OF TEARS AS THEY LEARNED
THAT THE DISNEY CORPORATION
MIGHT HAVE TO PAY TAXES.>> THE T
MACHINE AND MEMBERSILL PROCEED
TO VOTE.
[INDISTINCT CHANTING]
>> NOW IT IS THE VOTE.
68 YEAS, 36 NAYS, THE BILL
PASSES.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
YOU MAY HAVE SENSED E
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OVER THE LAST
DECADE OR SO HAS BEENAPTURED
BY CORPORATE INTERESTS.
BUT YOU NER THOUGHT YOU WOULD
AR ON THE FLOOR OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURDEMOCRATS SCREAM
WITH ANGUISH AT THE IDEA BIG
COMPANY MIGHT HAVE TO PAY ITS
TAXES.
UNBELIEVABLE.
BUT NOW VERY CLEAR.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
WELL,  LOT OF THINGS.
HERE'S ONE.
DISNEY SPENDS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ELECTING LMAKERS IN
THE STA OF FLORIDA.
THOSE LAWKERS COULD NOT DO
THEIR JOB IN THIS CASE AND ACT
ON DISNEY'S BEHALF.
THE L PASSED AND DeSANTIS
SIGNED INTO LAWHIS AFTERNOON
AND THATS GOING TO CAUSE THE
DISNEY CORPORATION A TON OF
MONEY, WHICH IN TURN MAY MEAN
LESS MONEY FOR THE FLORIDADEMOCG
IN T VIDEO.
SO THERE WAS SOME SELFNTEREST
INVOLVED HERE.
THERE I NOT JUST THAT BECAUSE
IT WAS NOT JUST DEMOCRATIC
OFFICEHOLDS WHO WERE UPSET BY
THE IDEA THAT AN ELECTED
GOVERNOR MIGHT BE MORE POWERL
THAN ANNELECTED CORPORATION
HEADQUARTERED ACROSS THE
CONTINENT.
THE MEDIA WERE VERY UPSET, TOO,
VERY UPSET.
WATCH THIS.
>> I RON DeSTIS CAN PASS AN
ANTI-MUSLIM BILL FOR THE STA
OF FLORIDA, HE WOULD.IF HE COULT
COME IF HE IT IS ILLEGAL TO SA
YOU ARE BLOCKED FROM I'M PRETTY
SURE THE GUY WOULD T IT.
>> LOOK, DeSANTIS, THIS IS A
PLAYBOOK OUT OF PUTIN ANDE SAW
WHERE THIS GOES.
IT IS WEIRD HOW REPUBLICANS
KEEP TACKING BK TO THE OLD
SOVIET UNION AND SEEM TO WANT TO
MIMIC THE THINGS THAT THE NEW
SOVIET UNION, MAINLY
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS DOING.
EVEN IN OUR CONRSATIONS ABOUT
DeSANTIS, IT IS ABOUT
HOW WELL THEY A SERVING HIM.
THE TRUTH IS, DEHUMANIZATION IS
TACTIC FOR POLITS IS FROM
WAR.
DEHUMANIZATION IS A TACTIC,
RUSSIANS GET THEIR SOLERS TO
RAPE CHILDREN BY A DEHUMANIZINGA
PRACTICE AS A TACTIC OF WAR.
>> Tucker: JT TO BE CLEAR
ANDLEARLY THERE IS AN INVERSE
IQ TEST GOING ON IN TH HIRING
DEPARTMENT AT MSNBC, BUT HERE
ARE THE NEW RULES: IFOU WOULD
LIKE A BIG PUBCLY HELD
COORATION TO PAY ITS TAXES,
THEN YOU ARE A CHI RAPIST,
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE A RACIST, LIKE
PUTIN Y ARE A FASCIST, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE YOU ARE?
ACCORDING TO JOY REID, YOU ARE A
COMMUNIST.
RON DeSANTIS IS "TAKING US
BACK TO THE SOVIET UNION," YOU
E A COMMUNIST IF YOU WANT THE
MPANY TOAY ITS TAXES.
JOY REID WENT TO HARVARD SOE